estaban de camino a ver a sus seres
queridos y familiares pero muchos no lo
lograron decenas de civiles intentaban
salir de zaporiya en un convoy de autos
para visitar a sus cercanos y llevarles
suministros cuando los misiles y la
metralla comenzaron dejando decenas de
muertos y heridos
sí esto es una respuesta a los éxitos de
nuestro ejército en la región de los
éxitos de nuestro ejército cerca de
liman una respuesta impotente del
profesional y segundo mejor ejército del
mundo
oficina
todo apenas unas horas antes de que
Rusia declarara oficialmente la anexión
del territorio junto a Lucas y a pesar
de que las autoridades rusas culpan a
Ucrania por los hechos el presidente
voló dimiercelenski prometió que pagarán
por el ataque el enemigo está enfurecido
intenta vengarse de nuestra firmeza y de
sus fracasos bastardos sanguinarios
definitivamente responderás por cada
vida ucraniana perdida Y es que Ucrania
sigue registrando ataques constantes en
nikolaive el impacto de un misil en
mitad de la noche provocó un incendio en
la ciudad
fue alrededor de la una de la madrugada
todo el mundo estaba durmiendo entonces
algo explotó y todo el mundo se levantó
rápidamente agarró a sus hijos lo dejó
todo y salió
Rusia ha negado repetidamente a atacar
objetivos civiles no obstante Ucrania
asegura contar con pruebas de que sus
misiles han alcanzado varias zonas
residenciales en todo el país